Welcome back everyone this will be my full marvel
moon knight episode 4 video there were a bunch of
easter eggs and references we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
your favorite moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll just start at the
beginning and talk about wtf moments and easter
eggs as we go along starting with the episode
titled the tomb obviously a reference to ahmed's
tomb that khonshu and the other gods locked her
earthly remains in 2000 years ago that's also
around the same time that they decided that they
would leave the mcu dimension they would leave the
third dimension and go to that pocket dimension
called the overvoid it's also when khonshu was
banished from the presence of the other gods he
was still forced to leave the earthly dimension
but he disagreed with them leaving he wanted to
stay on earth and continue to exact his vengeance
the way that he saw fit but there's a big easter
egg here too in this opening scene a lot of you
probably sensed this it's just like the black
panther movie it's an upside down shot and just
like the black panther movie they do a reverse
spin except this time it's osiris's avatar placing
conscious statue in his stone prison on a shelf
with many other similar stone figures sort of
foreshadowing what happened with omits remains
that we learned later in the episode remember
osiris's avatar said that many other gods were
trapped in this place in the same way that's what
all the other stone figures are are other god tier
characters that are part of conscious pantheon
they just weren't necessarily part of the ruling
council that any the ending itself like the ones
that we saw at the trial was only part of them but
they're only meant to be the ruling council over a
much larger group of gods that khonshu was part of
then they pick up with steven and layla in the
aftermath of episode three just immediately after
what had happened and they show you layla getting
her indiana jones on because it's still steven and
for most of this first action scene he's passed
out because of what happened with khonshu and the
other gods it's a very indiana jones-esque kind
of episode and she is an indiana jones figure
inside the mcu so they just want to show you that
she can actually hold her own in a regular fight
and they're fighting arthur harrow's men it's
not like superheroes fighting other superheroes
we'll get to that in later episodes like there
is a trailer shot probably from either episode 5
or episode 6 where you see moon knight and arthur
harrow both using their god tier power rushing at
each other so eventually just like marvel movies
it will work back up to that place where you see
gods vs gods there's an extended scene of steven
basically explaining what's been going on with
marc spector this whole time and they kind of have
this funny subplot with him falling in love with
leyla remember he's meant to be a different
personality so he's kind of meeting later for
the first time and he explains what their deal was
marc said that he was going to go away forever but
that was meant to be after they defeated arthur
harrow in ahmed which they haven't done yet so
that's why marc doesn't want to go away yet so a
lot of the episode goes back to that marc versus
steven place that they were in the first couple of
episodes with steven not wanting to have anything
to do with marc but they have started to work with
each other a little bit more and by the end of the
episode they do hug each other at the sight of
each other i will explain that too because it's
all right out of the comics as trippy as the
ending scene there is a very logical comic book
explainer it all makes sense don't worry steven
punching himself in his own face though is just
to show you how marc does have limited control
of their body even though he's technically not
supposed to be in control of the body steven
could do the exact same thing too if he were
the one that were stuck inside it's meant to be
kind of a parallel for the way that khonshu has
limited ability to physically interact with the
mcu unless he has his avatar with him the same is
true for all the other gods too like they have
a very limited ability to act on the mcu while
they're trapped inside this pocket dimension the
goat that they pass along the riverbed as they're
making their way to ahmed's tomb is meant to be a
representation of the egyptian god kanam who had
the head of a ram and was the god of the source
of the nile because they're literally walking
along a riverbed when steven starts yelling about
layla being the one to take care of them when they
go into the tomb you see the bloody tool on the
ground that's just meant to show you that layla
had just killed one of arthur harrow's men just
to show you that she was capable and steven not
knowing any kind of common caving techniques is
another example of the did that they suffer from
even though it's the same brain technically and
all that knowledge should be in there different
personalities inside his head don't have access
to all the same information that's why steven
is the egyptian history nerd marc is the hardcore
mercenary with the fighting skills and it sounds
like from the events of episode 3 jake lockley is
the stabby one there are also some jake lockley
references in the mental hospital later in the
episode too that i'll explain but it's another way
to show you why they'll have to eventually come
to an agreement like the personalities will all
stick around and they'll start working together in
a better way to become a more complete superhero
when he mentions being excited to answer a riddle
at the mouth of the cave when they look around the
ancient paintings he's talking about the riddle
of the sphinx there was actually a big connection
to king the conqueror in the sphinx in the loki
series to what's happening on moon knight right
now i just did a big kang the conqueror video
so i'll link that in the description below
but when kang first mastered time travel or he who
remains depending on which variant you're talking
about most of them did a lot of the same things
he took the name ramatut using his time machine to
travel back to ancient egypt and convince everyone
to worship him instead of the old gods that's one
of the major reasons that they cite an episode one
for the great rift the reason humanity eventually
would turn away from the old gods khonshu's
pantheon and why they chose to leave the mcu
blame it all on kang just took a couple thousand
years for that to set in but that's why you saw
the sphinx in the great pyramid during loki
episode five that was from a different timeline
that didn't go the way that kang wanted it to
go so that's why it wound up on that planet
then when they're actually trying to find omit
they learn all these really cool details and facts
about the actual tomb the tomb is a maze but it's
built to look like the eye of horus because of its
representation in the egyptian pantheon the way it
represented protection in the afterlife protection
against ahmed because remember the avatar
who built the tomb which we find out was
the pharaoh at the time and it was alexander
the great that's right mcu alexander the great
was the avatar of ahmet once upon a time the
reason why he would invoke protection against
omit would be because he sided with the other
gods rebelling against ahmed remember arthur
harrow told that big backstory her avatar rebelled
against her and helped entomb her 2000 years ago
they're also trying to backdoor explain why
alexander the great was able to conquer the known
world at the time because as an avatar he had the
powers of one of the gods him explaining what the
eye of horus is meant to represent is also meant
to set up the end of the episode because the eye
itself sort of represents the mind space as he
talks about the six senses there are also six
infinity stones but it sits at the end of the
episode where marc literally travels into his
own mind space don't worry we'll get to that too
that's part of a big comic book run that a lot
of you might remember if you're big moon knight
fans the first tomb that they find is covered
in blood with all the fresh canopic jars like
someone's been freshly mummified here and we see
it happen again later like multiple people are
being entombed here that belongs to one of the
guards that was mummified here left to protect the
pharaoh who we then find as alexander the great so
talk about easter eggs for the mummy movies arthur
harrow's men sort of activated these protection
measures which resurrected the mummy here which
has gone about trying to kill all the men slowly
the ushtabi figure that steven talks about the
figure that ahmed is bound to is exactly like
the figure that khonshu was bound to they're
just saying that the same thing that happened
to khonshu happened to ahmed 2000 years ago leyla
has this extended indiana jones type scene with
all the traditional traps you would expect that
she's trying to escape this mummy they even have
a classic jump scare talk about horror films can't
wait to see all the sam raimi horror easter eggs
during doctor strange 2 but then they reveal that
steven has in fact found the former avatar's tomb
they reveal it is alexander the great of the mcu
like i said 2000 years ago he helped rebel siding
with the other gods against ahmed when he learned
what she was planning to do judge the entire mcu
all the historical details that stephen tells
about him are meant to be true the only fake stuff
that they add in is all the marvel stuff about him
being an avatar in the real gods of the mcu but as
he foreshadowed earlier they travel to the tongue
within the maze the actual stone figure containing
amit's essence is stored literally in alexander
the great's mouth because he was her voice ha
ha see what they did there whoever wound up
mummifying alexander the great two thousand plus
years ago had a sense of humor but they had this
whole side story going on while this is happening
with leyla learning about her father and they're
basically doing a version of marc spector's
original comic book story the original moon knight
backstory the person that really wound up killing
her father was a version of bushman i think he
might actually wind up being a character on the tv
show but marc spector was a mercenary he actually
was doing shady things to earn money working with
bushmen but bushman going off the rails is exactly
what they say during the episode he rebelled
against him and then got shot died himself and
then was brought back to life because he made the
bargain with concho like he said i was supposed to
die that night but i didn't that's because that's
the night that he became moon knight the big twist
between them though is layla revealing that that
night is the first night that she met marc spector
so like he had literally just become moon knight
when they met for the first time i think what
they're trying to set up is a redemption arc
for marc spector as well as a redemption arc for
consho like they're on parallel arcs so khanshu
is trying to redeem himself in the eyes of the
other gods like look i'm telling the truth i'm not
such a dirtbag marc spector is trying to redeem
himself for all the terrible things that he did
tony stark iron man style so remember iron
man's backstory in the mcu he sold weapons
to the highest bidder he was a war profiteer
but eventually he became a superhero decided
to use his powers and his intellect for good the
same thing has kind of happened with marc spector
like he's trying to redeem himself for all the
terrible things that he did as a mercenary using
the powers of khonshu to become a superhero the
funny thing in the comics is that he actually does
become a millionaire because of all the money he
earns illicitly working as a mercenary so you can
make the billionaire playboy philanthropist joke
about moon knight except moon knight is just meant
to be a much darker character then i know there's
a billion questions about this whole end of the
episode where he falls into the water and then you
wind up inside this mental hospital arthur harrow
winds up getting him a couple times in the chest
notice their body shots they're not head shots
but one of konshu's biggest powers in the comics
is literally just resurrection marc spector dies
multiple times after becoming moon knight and each
time khonshu just brings him back like it's no big
deal but when he falls into the water what's
going on with his fake indiana jones looking
tv show is that it's meant to be a representation
of his stephen grant personality but the reason
why it's a vhs tape is because they're trying to
hint that he has been around since he was a child
when vhs was still common some of you are probably
old enough to remember buying vhs's at the store
back during the 90s that's basically what they're
saying here that the steven grant personality
even the jake lockley personality maybe has also
been around this entire time since he was a child
but the whole idea with this mental hospital
is this is right out of the moon i comic book
run and the way they presented it in the comics is
fairly similar to what the tv show's doing with it
marc spector got so messed up in the head
he found himself in this mental hospital
and he couldn't tell whether or not he just dreamt
up moon knight or if moon knight created him who
came first who was the real personality and he
wound up seeing a lot of familiar things and
artifacts objects from his recent life things
that represented things from his real life
that's why there's the goldfish here there's the
picture of khonshu there's the egyptian drawings
there's even a version of crowley that's the old
man here he's just not wearing the gold makeup
there's his boss donna sitting in the chair
there are cupcakes from his car chase in the
orderly as beck from episode 3 behind back behind
the cupcakes is the daily schedule on this board
on it reads bingo which they're in the middle
of during this mental hospital the other events
on the list are references to events that
have been happening in real life recently
you notice the police officers billy and bobby
that he saw during episode two there's even a
real life moonlight action figure and when the
version of layla says that they've changed the
movie five times this week and that's a lot that's
a reference to all the different personalities
from the comics there's up to five different
personalities in the comics there's marc spector
there's moon knight steven grant jake lockley
and mr knight i don't know if they're gonna do
every single different personality on the tv show
because mr knight for example in the comics was a
totally different personality but on the tv show
it's just steven wearing a version of the moon
knight suit the only alternate personality that
they've definitely confirmed we'll probably see
is jake lockley but in the comics what he wound
up finding out is that this was all happening
inside his head and it was just a scenario that
khonshu created to help him figure everything
out and then eventually he was able to come to an
agreement with his other personalities figure out
who he was and then come back to the real world
but it was all happening inside his head which is
basically what's happening inside the episode here
that's why marc and steven can interact with each
other physically like they can reach out and touch
each other there's a version of jake lockley that
looks like he's physically going to bust out
of that sarcophagus and they can see the true
form of the egyptian hippo goddess the bingo cards
they keep referencing in the episode are probably
a reference to him eventually hitting bingo when
he reconciles everything like they'll say bingo
and he'll come back out into the real world if you
watch the legion tv series this is just like that
like legion thought that he was crazy for a long
time but then he wound up finding out that in a
lot of cases the mental hospital was all just a
creation inside his head so even though arthur
harrow seems like he's meant to be this evil
psychiatrist figure in this scenario arthur harrow
himself is not controlling this scenario this is
all happening inside stephen grant's head he's the
one that has all the power he just doesn't realize
it yet you notice when he's inside his office the
office itself is like a white version of his evil
lair from episode two you also see statues and
figurines of all the other gods in the background
when the guards bust in you notice one of the
guards is literally one of the people we just saw
getting mummified while he was alive just to kind
of remind you oh this is actually happening inside
his head this isn't happening in the real world
when he talks about the villain and the tree
having to exist in the light and the dark at the
same time that's a reference to the way that the
mcu gods exist in this precarious balance between
light gods and dark gods like there are evil gods
and good gods all them are necessary for each
other to exist in this sort of precarious balance
and they police each other so to speak but it's
not a very equitable situation which is where you
get to the events of thor love and thunder where
gord the god butcher is like screw them all kill
all the gods they're more troubled than they're
worth they don't care about any of us i just did a
whole bunch of thor love and thunder trailer video
so i'll link that at the end of this as well yes
gorr the god butcher would be after khonshu and
the rest of his brothers and sisters that are part
of his pantheon the thing with gorr going after
the other gods that are part of khonshu's pantheon
eventually is it's just like gorr's mission in the
comics he starts small and then works up becomes
more and more powerful and is able to kill the
more powerful gods because not all mcu gods are
created equal even though the necro sword gives
him this cosmic power eventually he winds up
using some of the gods along the way to attain
even more power like eventually he forces the
god of bombs to create a giant god bomb for him
so that he can kill many of the gods at the same
time he also kills a group of gods that are gods
of time that allow him to time travel to the
beginning of time and absorb all this cosmic
power so that in his version of the timeline the
gods were never created he absorbed all that power
and he thinks that'll give him the ability to
completely get rid of the gods but at a certain
point it becomes hubris but you get the idea he
becomes more and more powerful so eventually he
would gain enough cosmic power killing enough gods
to travel to alternate dimensions so unless your
name is the one above all theoretically in the mcu
no god will ultimately be safe unless thor is able
to stop him during the events of the movie when
he references the lunar god he's talking about
khonshu because khonshu is the egyptian god of the
moon in addition to being the god of vengeance he
sees a painting representing that german town that
arthur harrow controlled during episode one then
he starts seeing the different tombs representing
the different personalities inside his head that
are trying to break out there could be more i
mean jake lockley is the only one that bangs
but doesn't quite get out we'll probably see him
in episode five or episode six but like i said
the reason why they opened that last door and
they're actually seeing the true depiction of
the egyptian hippo goddess her name is tarawet he
was referencing her during episode 1 when he was
talking about all the different plushie figures
of the gods she's also part of conscious pantheon
and she's also listed for the next couple of
episodes so that means we'll probably see more of
the actual gods in the next couple of episodes but
like i said the reason why both of them are able
to see her and like they're all in the same space
together is because the mcu gods can only appear
in people's minds because they're trapped outside
the mcu dimension if they were in the real world
stephen or marc or any of the other personalities
would not be able to see her i think part of the
idea though is at the beginning of episode 5 he'll
still be in the hospital and he'll talk to this
hippo goddess who will explain to him what's
really going on and he'll start to realize and
then eventually break back out into the real
world also another cool easter egg you may
have spotted if you keep watching the end credits
scene even though it seems like they're the same
in every single episode there are some minor
changes episode to episode during each episode
in the end credit scene the moon becomes more and
more full i think when we get to the finale it'll
reach full moon status and it's just meant to be
a reference to things on the show getting crazier
and crazier episode to episode as the moon gets
more and more full but if you spotted any other
big easter eggs in the episode that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments it was actually a pretty solid episode
i really like it when it gets trippy like this
legion was a lot of fun too if you're a big fan
of this kind of stuff watch the legion tv series
my episode 5 trailer video will post next in
my full moon knight episode 5 video we'll post
next week after they release it everyone click
here for my full thor love and thunder trailer
video to learn more about the mcu gods and
click here for my brand new rune king thor
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!